well perjury I'm doing the thing for
list all too clear what do you mean I'm
not getting pregnant okay okay hold hold
on are you telling me that I won't be
getting paid for this
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to I've
heard of worse ways to try and get
Nicolas Cage into the Avengers
I guess Nicolas Cage was so good at
making it look like his skull was
burning out of his face that this seemed
like an inevitable decision Ghost Rider
based on the famous Marvel Comics series
he's arguably the fucking coolest
looking thing conceived since bacon
robot demon slayer it's mine so how can
an idea as friggin awesome as this
possibly go astray well getting the
writer and director of daredevil
electron Jack Frost is a good fucking
start yeah the guy who made something
that's supposed to be adorable
terrifying and something that's supposed
to be terrifying adorable wearing good
fucking hands let's finish off Nicolas
Cage month with Ghost Rider the movie
starts with Sam Elia giving an opening
narration which immediately makes me
think we're watching a Chevy truck
commercial it said that the West was
built on legends tall tales that help us
make sense of things too great were too
terrifying to believe this is the legend
of the Ghost Rider talking about he
speaks of a person who did the devil's
bidding until he came across a contract
of a thousand souls but that contract
was so powerful he knew he could never
let the devil get his hands on it yeah
so is she the paper is the big end all
this movie has to offer because there's
nothing more terrifying than legal
ramifications so he did what no writer
has ever done before
he outran the devil himself so what
you're saying is the devil in this world
is a pretty label the thing about
Legends is sometimes they're true and
sometimes there's some RAM okay I'm
getting my big basket jar here cuz trust
me I'm gonna need it thus the credits
burned through the screen to reveal
Bowser's Castle on level 4 of mario kart
[Music]
cut two years later as we see a young
daredevil named Johnny Blaze we're
taking in a father-and-son act
presumably called the flaming speed
racers but his father doesn't like how
he's trying to impress his girlfriend in
the audience you're already screwing
around I was just doing it for the crowd
don't know why you've done it she's
gonna stand by you when you're in a
wheelchair
huh hotshot I never would have expected
a daredevil will be such a short but
thanks get complicated was girlfriend
named Roxanne played by Eve Mendez tells
her beau that she has to leave and isn't
me are you waiting for Albert Finney's
big fish narration to take over any
minute we'll jump on the back and just
keep going tomorrow noon when we hear
it was then that I realize my adventures
have just begun all leading up to when I
dressed and dragged on that island in
summer Isle that was a weird weekend he
discovers though that he can't leave
because his father found out he's dying
of cancer which is news to a certain
Horned one's ears played by peter fonda
worried about your father thing about
cancer is the time it takes it changed I
couldn't help but notice your
cartoonishly silly shadow are you
perchance a Muppet of sorts would you be
willing to make it you name your price
I'll take your soul you're from Google
aren't you look I already signed up for
Google Plus even though I don't need it
how much more control of my life do you
what Blais agrees of course to make a
contract with him and his father's
miraculously saved from certain death
only to accidentally slip into certain
death and then og who woulda thought you
can't trust the devil you're no good to
me
do you killed him I are currently ask
you to pull my finger in defiance I'll
be watch so the double claims him as his
property which means he can't run off
with his girlfriend he doesn't even give
her an excuse he just looks at her and
rides off like the wind or rain there's
some bullshit and we cut ahead years
later to the reveal of our star the cage
man he's transformed into the most
famous daredevil in the world but his
helpers question how he's been able to
survive so many injuries without a
scratch for so long you should be taking
a dirt nap after that ragdoll today I
got lucky you got an angel looking after
you
maybe it's mabeline but not too far away
we get the reveal of our main villain
played by West Bentley just like doing
that at random you know just walking
across empty desert and suddenly going
right
it may seem pointless to you but if
there happened to be a camera in front
of me it may possibly scare a
seven-year-old but not an adult because
that'd be childishly silly but I'm gonna
keep doing it cuz you know it's it's fun
it's just my thing you know I just mean
NES folks this is what the villain of
our movie looks like because isn't this
who you want to see Nicholas fucking
cage go up against that bag filming
pussy from American Beauty oh yeah it's
just as good as when they teamed up vin
diesel against kat dennings or Dwayne
the rock Johnson against Tyler Perry is
Madea or Mark Wahlberg against that
snowman from frozen don't underestimate
him he bites so he takes out Curley of
Hell Stooges and calls upon his minions
a rejected matrix concept art well
that's goin on Kate get settled into his
garage where he looks to relax before
his next big stunt got a lot of
expensive bikes in here man I told you
before I'll say it again this place
could use a woman's touch so could you
all right four out of five rack one more
you get the whole set actually want to
talk to you about something kind of
serious it's about you jumping on the
anniversary of your dad's accident yeah
let's see what other exposition to I
miss out here oh yeah
books you still like to read books JB on
this the anniversary of your father's
death I'm trying to relax Mac yeah I
understand all right it's just gonna
take a second and I'm not even kidding
I swear to god I'm not making this up
cages idea of relaxing in this movie is
pouring jelly beans into a martini glass
and laughing at videos of monkeys doing
karate
you know why is it I get the feeling
that Nicolas Cage wouldn't do this movie
unless this specific setup was in it
would it really surprise you
unfortunately mr. cage we were unable to
ride in a scene where you juggle flaming
ukuleles and scoped kitty litter however
we did get that scene for you where you
drink jelly bellys and watch monkeys
practicing kungfu were you at least able
to have be surfing elephant breath while
eating my dreams
no mr. cage that's impossible to
visualize it frees the elephant breath
into a solid mass then okay I want you
to create a machine that could take
dreams and make them physical so that I
can consume them for nourishment
[Music]
was that so hard
mr. Caid I'm sorry but unfortunately our
budget will only allow for jelly bellies
and monkey kong foo burwell so just see
how my demands are being met hard liquor
man so he's just about to do his biggest
stunt when he comes across his old flame
Roxann who's now a reported that he
gives what many would consider a very
typical Nicolas Cage interview Johnny
what drives somebody to risk their life
for entertainment I heard you got
married
most of the time the press focuses on
the crashes the broken bones the cost of
what you do there any other calls
the end ah why do I get a terrible
feeling that this demonic hell spawn a
fire and awesomeness is just gonna be a
guy waking up for two hours so he does
his jumbo realizes he wanted to talk to
Roxanne some more
[Music]
I can green-screen some more effects if
you want hold on why don't I make it
more convincing by adding the Navi and
Jar Jar Binks to the mix I love you long
time so he finally stops them and he has
a nice long conversation with her
look you were 17 and you witnessed a
tragedy and you ran and I understand now
I'm like I understood then and I have no
hard feelings none you know that's why
they call it the past cuz it's past it's
done actually I call this the if I did
in real life I'd probably be arrested
yes it worked great in the notebook yeah
so cage is finally on a date and after
years and years of regret and
frustration suddenly giving him another
chance
what does cage do with this opportunity
show up late because he's too busy
looking at himself in the mirror you
deserve a second chance
typical cage ISM this makes Roxanne so
upset that she checks her magic 8-ball
wait what
[Music]
movie that's teenage my little pony
fanfiction bad is there also an anvil in
her purse to knock herself out in case
she sees something else that might shock
her a cage is interrupted from his
incredibly important mirror watching by
the fires of Fonda who now tells him
that cage as the writer must stop his
son from getting the contract which he
spontaneously now for some reason
decides he wants I guess you just hit
puberty and you suddenly want the
contract of a thousand souls go figure
you're under contract remember if you
succeed
I'll return your soul you know I guess
it's kind of fitting seeing how easy
rider' is passing on a mission too
difficult in any way to get emotionally
attached writer
so the devil's son and his Drew's tried
to locate cage but come across a man in
his Lantern Oh for fuck's sake movie but
what the flying hell does anyone carry a
lantern unless you're in the haunted
mansion or scooby-doo episode you use a
fucking flashlight you really shouldn't
be here
that's what they keep telling me but
cage drops in as he finally starts to
transform into The Ghost Rider
[Music]
and there's no CG being used here folks
Cage can just set himself ablaze
whatever he's asked
and I'm not gonna lie what ghostrider is
on screen it's pretty fucking awesome
looking for someone granted his voice
isn't really anything that interesting
but then again I guess it would be even
stranger if it was still Kjus voice
coming out of it you turn me on
you turn me on um you're not too tall
you're not too short you're not too
round so the writer is ready to kick
some ass until he's nailed by Nicolas
Cage's great his arch nemesis is with
Nicolas Cage and trucks if he's not
dreaming about them hitting little girls
he's getting hit by them in real life
maybe Optimus Prime just likes punking
with celebrities come on Autobots
but scare the shit outta Whoopi Goldberg
effects oh cage does manage to get out
and get his revenge
ashes to ashes dust top fuck
you should have had me what that goddamn
truck
so after chasing the evil Planeteers
away he tours around town trying to take
even more evil souls to hell one of them
understandably so
trying to acts off rebel Wilson Thanks
I'm off to ask Conan O'Brien to finance
a horrible sitcom well you have no
website yet somehow you still form
consonants so he takes his soul to hell
has himself a good sleep and ends up in
a cemetery owned by of course Sam Elliot
who knows all about it
I say something funny bigger already
around here that buzz shit oh yeah I
forgot it's Sam Elliot a man who's made
a mumbling dialect from his inability to
eat his own mustache doner got a nice
cozy spot for you I mean does that some
sort of an Eastern thing things are made
much better when cage and Elliot have to
carry on a conversation of mumbles
sterile Finisterre and there been others
sterilized attention so he tells him
that the devil's son and his minions
were angels cast out of heaven and also
we won the name of the devil son - you
ready for this no seriously are you
ready for this it's it's pretty funny
let's just have to do it black art
[Music]
Blackheart okay I am totally convinced
that this was originally a Care Bears
cartoon I mean think about it the silly
shadow the guy with the lantern the
fucking 8-ball this is all stuff you'd
see in a preschool Saturday morning
lineup and now the villains name is
black heart fucking black heart if I
call your villain dark bad or mean poop
I mean with all this talk of the devil
and fallen angels and such do you really
think that this part made it into the
Bible you think that was actually the
devil child's name well I don't want
step on anyone's religious toes so let's
just double check it to be sure oh wow
revelations 2010 and the devil that
deceived them was cast into the lake of
fire and brimstone along with his son
hee hee ha ha his son twit heckle heckle
I can't believe I'm saying this his son
Blackheart bwahaha okay guys who's
punking me Wow
God does have a sense of humor
[Applause]
[Music]
tired of cleaning the house with those
oily rags that just seemed to move the
dirt around well why don't you try Sam
Wow
the only towel endorsed by Sam Elliot
the instructions are very simple and
just as Sam mentioned Sam watt works on
any surface except for latex which would
cause a burning reaction if it came in
contact with human skin Sam Wow because
somebody needs to soak up all that blood
and remember
see you for him again more than good
sarsaparilla
[Music]
[Applause]
laughter Kade realizes he can summon
fire through his fists and tried to
scare himself in the mirror hey to be
fair at scarier than this I'm gonna get
ya he apologizes to Roxane who
rightfully so isn't pleased that he
abandoned her once again that is until
later that night what she realized that
she somehow was wrong I came to
apologize I'm leaving town tonight and
man I didn't want what I said today to
be the last words between us okay lady
what the fuck is wrong with you you had
nothing to apologize for this other guy
who abandoned you when you were gonna
run away forever with him and then never
showed up when he was trying to make
amends mostly because he was just
staring at himself in the goddamn mirror
he seemed to do a lot of that in this
movie
these are big asshole issues and yet
you've constantly treated it like he's
building mustard on your dress or
something oh well at least she's saying
goodbye it isn't dumb enough to
spontaneously go back to him she gains a
pawn that don't go back and forth as
much as you do and still what does Kage
end up doing okay I've never seen him
landing lights more clearly labeled to
get the fuck out of a relationship and
yet she still tries to fight for his
heart you almost kill yourself on the
highway so you can ask me out and then
you don't show they keep my picture but
when I kiss you you try to shove me out
the door what don't you care about me at
all Johnny the way I am no logical sense
care for you so he finally gives her a
logical explanation she can at least
comprehend I saw my son the devil
well most women would kick you in the
rocks were saying something so stupid
but you thrown an eyebrow like that and
suddenly you go from Ghost Rider to
Flynn Rider for the devil oh yeah I'm
his bounty hunter but it only happens at
night like it is right now so tonight
you'll
I believe soon which is why it's
probably a very good idea that you you
run on whom look this worked when I
broke up with eight other chicks I'm not
sure why is having no effect on you I
realized that you rather make up
ridiculous stories and be honest with me
she does end up not believing in big
surprise so I guess it's time for some
proof it's a go you're shooting flames
out of your fists and now you're just
hoping she trusts your fucking word
would you believe me if I said I was
Superman
but the COS figure out he's the one
ripping up the town and throw him in
jail which causes him to start going
crazy from being around so much evil
looks like somebody's trippin I'm a big
shot out there place putting here you're
nothing but a monkey in a cage and don't
you know you don't put a monkey in a
cage you put a cage in a bear it just
makes more sense so all the evil brings
out the rider and once again it's pretty
bad as to watch but sadly the badassness
meter decreases when you remember he's
going up against team Hot Topic
hmm you'll just love my toxic lock
things don't get much better when the
police start to hunt him down but he has
an awesome way out of that so he takes
out Bob James Franco Marley and starts
heading back
okay that was pretty fucking awesome
throwing a few flaming doves on that one
[Music]
and try not to hit the woman we let walk
in front of us for some reason
so raxiom makes her way to cages home
because clearly no police will be
looking for them there I think the cops
in this town mostly consists of this and
of course Bank Filner is waiting do I
almost gotcha it's a little bit of a
flinch there little bit of which no body
out half side your penance stance and
work on me he also forgot to mention
that you can't choke a skeleton but
whatever he knocks him down and tells
him that he's taking his lady friend you
don't work for my father anymore you
work for me get the contract from the
caretaker bring it to me in San venganza
I'll be waiting at the Spencer's gifts
where I work so he goes back to Sam
Elliott who apparently has had the
contract all along but why the hell
should he hand it over
he may have my soul he doesn't have my
spirit any man who's got the guts to
sell his soul for love the power to
change the warning oh yeah hey this is
my little pony fan fiction can you just
see an episode ending like that anyone
who would give their soul for wealth has
the power to change the world
isn't that right ghost pony rider
right so Elliot reveals that he was the
original writer and decides to ride with
cage finally showing his true form it's
time to deliver a badass climax of fiery
biblical proportions with these two cuz
you know the truth for me huh I got
nothing left
I could only change one more time saving
for this wait a minute you didn't save
it to help him battle evil to save the
world you saved it to be a cool-looking
GPS so cool change from an earlier scene
Samaritan are you trying to make things
right ever since thank you
[Music]
they measure mistakes the most recent
one being wasting that flaming horse
thing Thank You kid
[Music]
yeah if I need directions to an
all-night Taco Bell I'll be sure to
summon your blaze again or if I ever
lose my cellphone in the dark I'll call
upon your fiery glow once more I won't
just use a flashlight or a lantern which
apparently we're still using this
fucking dumbass universe starting to see
why Stanley didn't cameo in this stupid
piece of shit so Kate suits up to Howard
Brendan Fraser and The Mummy put it
again rescue the damsel in distress kill
the bad guy you save the world
yeah that as he hands over the contract
but finds he can't become the writer
when the Sun comes up
so the badass in the cool code fights
the whiny rebellious goth kid half his
age as little demons fly into his body
making him the most powerful entity in
the world I'm sorry I was reciting the
climax to Blaine how silly of me here's
the climax - Ghost Rider the badass in
the cool coat fights the whiny
rebellious goth kid half his age as
little demons blind to his body making
him the most powerful entity in the
world God silly Mika fusing the two my
name is
[Music]
for we are
and seeing how we are many we all took a
vote to see if we should talk normally
or stretch out our vowels like dark
heart these socage tries to shoot him
because yeah the most powerful thing the
world I'm sure can be stopped by a
shotgun which actually he kind of Ken
weird but he manages to get him in the
shadows where his powers can still work
oh yeah probably should have thought
about that whole becoming a thousand
souls in front of the guy who can kill a
thousand souls whoops
so Kage axes him off as the devil is
pleased and offers him a chance to go
back to normal you get your life back
the love you've always wanted you can
start a family of your own let someone
else carry this curse your freedom must
think of bullshit a reason for sequel
must find way to ditch girlfriend again
I'm gonna own this curse whenever
innocent blood is spilt it'll be my
father's blood
and you'll find me there the spirit of
vengence i will make you famous I mean
you didn't put any emotion in that seat
I'm starting to wonder if we got the
real Nicholas Cage this of course means
abandoning his woman again only this
time the reasons are even kind of stupid
this is what you always were meant to be
that your second chance don't worry
we'll meet under more embarrassing
circumstances and bad lieutenant port of
call New Orleans and cage rides off into
the desert and the most cartoonishly
weird way possible which is very fitting
seeing how the rest of this movie was
pretty much like lumpy cartoon
[Music]
so that was ghostwriter and when there
was actual ghostrider in it it was kind
of cool
maybe I'm just a sucker for the visual
but every time that Segal is on stream
the movie seems like pretty badass body
but in a surprising move cage really
kind of under plays it which at times
can work to offset some of the
strangeness that was rare but most the
time it's just boring maybe he was
hoping the contrast of the visual to his
monotone delivery would even it out but
if the movie want to be more fun if he
should have played it like castor Troy
or one of his other over-the-top words
this is just sort of underwhelming
though as the movie is all foamed in
comic book tricks and not the fun
inventive once more the ones you've seen
a million times but the filmmakers think
you're seeing for the first time for
some reason it's stupid silly cliched
which is usually fine for a cage fill
but in this case it was just born and it
takes a lot of skill to make a character
as cool-looking as is born so yeah mr.
director go back to scaring us with your
creepy a snowman because this stinker
shirring keepin anyone awake thanks for
joining me for Nicolas Cage month I hope
you enjoyed it and well there's only one
person fit enough to exit us out the big
man himself Sam Elliot I coulda said it
better myself
I'm gonna sound you critic in a new year
Amanda sees on the way
[Music]
[Applause]
and remember kids some other buckers are
always trying to ice skate uphill
[Music]
you
smelly